>> BRIN: Hi. Welcome to Mountain View, California.
I'm speaking here at Google's Headquarters.
And I'd like to tell you about something I'm
really excited about. It's called Android
and it's a new open source operating system
and software platform for mobile phones. Just
like I learned how to write great services
in software upon free tools for the web like
Linux and GNU, now with Android you'll be
able to do the exact same things on mobile
phones. The software is all free, the source
is completely available, and we expect great
new powerful applications to be developed
on it. The SDK is being released right now
and you can download it. And to show you some
of the highlights and some of the applications
we've already developed, here's Steve.
>> HOROWITZ: You've probably been hearing
a little bit about the G-Phone lately. I'm
here to tell you there is actually no G-Phone.
Instead, I'd like to introduce you to the
Android platform. This is a platform, we hope,
will enable people to create thousands of
G-Phones. The first device I'd like to show
you today is a prototype that I've been living
with for about the past six month, because
in order to create a great product, you actually
have to live with it. This particular device
is running a full version of the Android software
stack that has all the functionality you would
expect in a basic phone. Here's an example
of a home screen. This is a place where you
have access to all of your favorite applications,
such as your browser, maps or contacts. If
you want to call somebody, just type their
name and hit dial. And I'm calling my friend,
Erin. Of course, one of the things that we've
built into the software development kit is
the ability to interact and integrate applications
with one another. So another example using
contacts, let's say I want to find out where
Erin lives. I simply go and type her name.
And when I bring up her contact and select
her address, it'll take me right to the maps
application and it's going to zoom right in
to show me where Erin lives. If I click "see
on the map," then we notice that she lives
on Amphitheatre Parkway. But maybe I'm not
quite sure where that is, so I want to zoom
out a little bit to see what freeway that
might be close to. There, we can see that
it's near the Highway 101. Now, if we go back
to the home page, one of the other things
I want to show you is the ability for devices
using the Android platform to receive notifications.
For example, here, I just received the notification
from my friend, Lexi, that says, "Eh, pizza
sounds good." That must be what she wants
for dinner. You noticed that it first showed
up at the top of the screen and it told me
that--the contents of that message. If I want
to go and read that message, all I have to
do is navigate up and you can see--oh, there's
my notification from Lexi. It says "Pizza
sounds good." If I want to reply, I just hit
the enter key and I can go into my text messaging
application and say, "Great," and away we
go. It sounds like we're having pizza for
dinner tonight. The next device I'd like to
show you is a more high-end prototype that
includes advanced features, such as high-speed
3G networking, accelerated 3D graphics, and
a touch screen. Let me show you the browser
application. A Web browser is based on the
open source WebKit. The industry standard
these days, it's the one that allows you to
see Web pages just as they would appear on
your desktop. The other thing that you'll
notice about a web browser is that it's loading
over the fast 3G data network. This device
is capable of accessing the Internet at 3G
speeds and loading web pages quite fast. Now,
the pages loaded here and we're zoomed in
a little bit. So, if I want to see more of
the page, I can simply grab it and pan around
a little bit. And if I want to see the page
in its full glory, I can simply zoom out and
see it just as what it would appear on my
desktop. We also have a rich visual history
for our browser. Go in here, and I can look
at the history for my browser and I can see
all the sites that I visited recently. The
next application I like to show you is global
time. This shows you the rich graphical powers
of the Android platform. And in this case,
it's using the 3D OpenGL ES to render a globe
here and allow me to very easily spin it with
my finger. I can also play with the earth
while it's spinning around. The Android graphics
API allows you to very easily mix 3D and 2D
graphics. Next, I'd like to show you some
of the advanced 3D hardware capabilities of
this prototype using "Quake." Any application
that is written to the Android OpenGLs API's
will be able to take full advantage of any
hardware acceleration. Now, I'd like to show
you the Maps application. I happen to be here
at the City of San Francisco. Using the touching
capabilities of this device, I can pan around
the city of San Francisco and watch those
map tiles load for me at 3G speeds. One of
the benefits of the Android platform is that
we build in basic functionality like map views
so your application doesn't have to reinvent
all the functionality in maps if you want
to build something on top of it. Here I am
at the Embarcadero in street view, starting
from wherever I was on maps. If I want to,
I can simply take my finger and I can move
that image around and I can pan around and
see what the Embarcadero looks like. I can
also zoom in. That was just a preview of some
of the things the Android platform can do.
We can't wait to see what developers will
come up with next.
>> BRIN: Welcome back, I hope you enjoyed
seeing some of the applications we have built
all ready. But the best applications are not
here yet. That's because they're going to
be written by you and many other developers
just like you. We'd like to reward these developers
and to recognize them as much as possible.
So we've set aside $10 million, which we're
going to give away to the people who develop
the best applications using Android. We're
looking forward to seeing some really great
apps: ones which are innovative; make use
of the great functionality available in Android
and on mobile phones; and things that are
really original that haven't been seen before.
I look forward to seeing all of your work.